open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five Sara's in West
Virginia hi Sarah how are you great how
are you better than I deserve what's up
well I'm not husband night and I'm have
to say listening and we are a babysit
one we only have $500 say don't say for
about a month and an opportunity has
oddly aroused for us to be moving and
staked and this that gives me a $13,000
a year raise and my husband is worried
that if we were to move out of state and
be paying a normal rent that we wouldn't
be able to reach maybe step 2 as quickly
or as easily as we would if we were to
stay here one and so I'm well we rent
from family and our ranch is only three
18 months which is extremely low and I
think she's worried that if we were to
go to someone that's $700 a month or
something then we wouldn't be able that
we would just be in a different the
second okay let's do some math okay $300
a month more and rent is what we're
talking about right right times 12 is 36
hundred dollars a year $3,600 more in
rent but you said your raises thirteen
thousand mine would be you would have to
find a job down there what does he make
now he makes about 22 okay and what does
he do now with the both work for a
shelter for especially as foster kids
and what would he be doing if he went
down there probably something similar he
really likes to work what do you what we
what do you make now
I think 21 okay all right so you're
going to cut your household income in
half but add 13 back so you can't make
this move unless he lands a job right if
he lands a job at making 22 or more the
and this is a $13,000 raise - $3,600 in
increase in rent you come out ahead 10
grand right that's what I thought as
well it's kind of math I mean it's not a
matter of it's not a matter of opinion
it's just a map thing now where are you
talking about moving to North Carolina
okay and your family's all in West
Virginia no I have some family down in
North Carolina which is why we were
eventually choosing to wear down their
family will yes yes in West Virginia I
think we found the real problem it's not
a math problem he doesn't want to leave
West Virginia right ah that's let me
talk through that's not a personal
finance issue that's a where do I want
to live issue and either ones okay with
me both find places West Virginia is
great place so don't look at your life
wherever you guys won't leave just go
but you need to be on the same page
about that and let's not use money
arguments to make another argument how
about I just love West Virginia I don't
wanna leave that's an okay thing to say
if that's him that's okay